mach dich noch schön
jalich hallo Mona
dankein hallo das ist das Kaminzimmer
des wie schön ja haben die hier
umgeräumt od bist du ja auch öfter zu
Gast als
Kölnerin das ein oder andere Mal ich fin
ja sehr
mauscheligette
Atmosphäre ich bin ein bisschen Auer
Puste kein Problem wir Ken erstmal ganz
gemütlich Kamin machen wir nicht an
Vorsicht was machen wir nicht an Kamin
nein ach der ist aus normalerweise an
hier war vorher ganz
plüschig ich überlege ganz guten
Geschmack hier ich den ich überlege ob
ich noch mal auf die Toilette gehen soll
weil ich ja immer so ein hnrang hab du
hast von mir aus gerne bis
gleich das heißt eine große Fernsehshow
wä nichts für dich mit 90 Minuten Länge
und ne kannst muss immer Pipi aber ich
habe mich beilt wenn man Händewaschen
wegässt dann geht's ja schneller okay
ähm ich hat letztlich ein Regisseur
neben mir der musste auch aufs Klo ich
habe gesagt ich schwitze das immer aus
nee das geht nicht also
muss echt oft auf Klo auch Nacht und
dann immer Augen zu und ich genau ich
kenne ja die Wege und so und dann darf
auch keine ger sonst bin ich dann wach
und dann kann ich mal Einschlafen na ja
gut andere haben Krankheiten gut das ist
noch eines Problem ja wie ist die L
wunderbar sehr sehr positiv habe gerade
netten Menschen kennengelernt vorher
bevor ich hier hingekommen bin ganz
zufällig aber du bist verheiratet eine
Frau war das
Al aber es hat auch gar nichts Sexuelles
ja und
das ist natürlich dann immer wunderbar
und ich bin mir geht's gut bin entspannt
von daher ist die Lage wunderbar super
wie wie lernst du Menschen kennen bist
du besonders kontaktfreudig oder mir
passiert das einfach ich ich glaube dass
ich das ausstrahle nicht dass ich die
ganze Zeit Leute anquatsche aber ich
glaube dass ich irgendwie im Kontakt bin
mit Menschen dass ich nicht so also ich
beobachte viel und ich nehme viel wahr
und dann gibt's Reaktion und das Fühlen
die Menschen oder man sendet das einfach
aus und von da ich kommen sehr viel mit
Menschen in Kontakt und vor allen Dingen
das das schöne mit sehr viel
unterschiedlichen Menschen also bei mir
kann das wirklich sein dass ich im Taxi
nach Hause fahre irgendwie nachts um 1
und dann vor der Tür mit dem Taxifahrer
3 Stunden erzähle und dann nach Hause
gehe und total glücklich
bin passiert sowas passiert mir öfter
ist das dann nur oberflächlich oder nein
eben nicht sonst dre Stunden ist dann
schwierig an der Oberfläche vor allen
Ding auch langweilig
aber ich weiß auch nicht also es es
kommt immer dazu also meine Freundin
oder Freunde sagen dann auch wie was
machst du denn immer dass du mit den
gleich so dass da so auf einmal so eine
Nähe ist auch ne natürlich wie Nähe sein
kann wenn man sich nicht kennt aber
schon dass man wirklich ein fruchtbares
und intensives Gespräch geführt hat wo
ich auch rausgehe und für mich
persönlich einen großen Gewinn spüre und
was dann so einfach so
menschenfreundlich ist wo man sich alles
Gute wünscht und also wenn ich in in der
Bäckerei sitze und ein Brötchen esse und
da sitzt eine alte umi neben mir und es
da ist irgendwas das kann auch nur über
ein Lächeln sein oder über etwas was man
gemeinsam gesehen hat und dann lacht man
und dann kommt man ins Gespräch und
redet dann und am Ende landet man bei
den Werten es ist ja immer so und
was man sich wieder wünscht oder was wie
man also nicht so ein Jammern und Klagen
sondern eher was kann
man was kann man in seinem kleinen
Umfeld machen damit es schöner wird oder
was HBT man hervor und was welchen Ding
gibt man Bedeutung und welche werden
dadurch größer und so weiter diese
Ernsthaftigkeit die ich jetzt jetzt
feststelle ist das ich sag mal ein ganz
wichtiger Bestandteil wenn man Comedy
machen will braucht man in seiner
Persönlichkeit so einen sehr ernsten
Teil einen sehr Wachen Teil einen
politischen Teil
oder meinst das ein hat mitm anderen
nichts zu tun hat ja viel miteinander zu
tun also braucht man wenn man ich we ich
bin doch ke lachsag ich mich nicht dahin
die ganze Zeit gut drauf den und jetzt
was
lustiges sein man gar nicht lustig sein
kann wenn man keinen ernsten Hintergrund
hat ich kann das für andere nicht sagen
ich weiß nicht wie das andere Kollegen
bei mir ist es völlig ernst also ich
Menschen die
mich zuerst durch die Kamera
kennenlernen und dann wirklich
kennenlernen sind teilwe total
enttäuscht oh du bist ja so ernst lach
doch mal das heißt nicht dass ich nicht
lache oder so aber es
ist Komik produzieren und komisch sein
das ist was anderes es gibt Menschen die
können bei einem Grillfest unterhalten
die den ganzen Abend und die Leute
finden es brüllkisch und die haben
Mutterwitz und haben diese Energie und
dieses positive und und können einfach
Menschen in eine positive und lustige
Stimmung
versetzen und stellst du die von der vor
die Kamera und den der muss zum
Fernsehen ja Schreien der muss zum
Fernsehen dann steht da da Krieg kriegt
die Zähne nicht aus das sind einfach
zwei vollkommen unterschiedliche Dinge
und und ich bin nicht ein Typ der aufem
auf einem Grillfest sich auf den Tisch
stellt und sagt und jetzt noch ein und
so und hört mal den gibt solche es gibt
Komiker die und das meine ich die auch
auch sehr ho jetzt komme ich und die
immer so den
entertainfaktor immer dabei haben die
immer lockere Sprüche
und die bewegt das ununterbrochen und
das ist bei mir komplett anders und das
kenne ich auch von anderen Kollegen die
da das ist wie Jackel und HDE also wie
kommt man dann auf die Idee Comedy zu
machen weil sagt ein ja keiner du musst
zum Fernsehen du machst so Keile
Grillfeste ja bei mir war es eben schon
durch die Resonanz also einfach weil ich
in den Gesichtern das gelesen habe dass
ich was mat haben und die Leute gelacht
haben und
das ja diese Resonanz gab und aber ich
war ganz sicherlich nie jemand auch als
Kind schon mal gar nicht ich war völlig
still und unsichtbar und
null dieses hurra und wann kommt endlich
das Fernsehen und entdeckt mich
überhaupt nicht das
ist mir auch bis heute nicht angenehm
ist dir nicht angenehm nein find das
alles unangenehm
na toll also kein traumschop oder was ne
wirklich nicht ich bin Autorin fühle
mich nicht als
Schauspielerin bin Autorin das bin ich
gerne und wenn ich alleine bin am
Schreibtisch und schreiben kann und in
die Natur Blicke und mit und dann auch
mit anderen zusammenarbeite das mache
ich auch gern und ich bin sehr zweier
fixiert immer auch und das finde ich
toll aber so dieses in in den Fokus rein
und
das bringt irgendwie so mein mein eher
so meinen inneren See es sind mir zu
viel Wellenschläge aber wenn dann an so
einem Set da ist dann dieses Schwarze
Loch und dahinter dann noch noch mal 40
Leute und so
und das ist eine ganz andere Form von
Kontakt und dann musst du natürlich auch
oberflächlicher sein wie willst du denn
sonst mit allen handtieren das finde ich
sehr konfus das
das ist dann ja auch immer so einer und
viele ne so hier ist meh eine
Gemeinschaft von meinem Empfinden her
und beim anderen ist so Mauer
menschenmauer und deswegen ich war ja
nie auf der Bühne finde ich gruselig das
heißt für dich also ich kenne ja
comediens oder kartisten die sagen ja
das ist für mich Therapie da auf der
Bühne so eine Selbstüberwindung ist es
für dich gar nicht na ja klar muss ich
mich überwinden aber es ist du möchtest
es eigentlich also ist nicht was was du
brauchst ne das würde ich gerne
abstellen also ich finde den Zustand
toll ich finde den Zustand zu spielen
den reinen Zustand das was durch Dich
fließt und dieses ausdenken die
Vorarbeit ich bin ganz akribischer
Vorarbeiter weiß genau was ich dann
möchte ich ich gehe da sehr tief rein
und bin ganz lange damit
beschäftigt und dann eben zu spielen und
mit den Kollegen zu spielen ich spiele
auch nicht so gern allein spiel lieber
mit anderen zusammen und
das finde ich toll also der reine Zusand
aber das Drum warum und das finde ich
anstrengend ist nichts was ich brauche
das ist schon paradox ja so bin
ich aber deine Umwelt kommt damit
zurecht mal ja man Nein
ne ja ich muss ja auch durch mich selber
durch müssen die anderen das auch was
soll ich machen dann danke ich vielmals
ich h du hast gewusst auf was du dich
hier heute eingelassen hast nee kanst
und gar nicht wie hätte ich das denn
wissen sollen nee aber ich habe mich
wohl gefühlt habe auch die ganze Zeit
gebrabbelt habe mich vorher schon mal
eingeredet das auch bei mir wenn ich
wenn ich vorher nicht reden würde eine
Stunde vorher dann würde ich hier die
Zähne nicht auseinander kriegen das
heißt was hast du gemacht BL die ganze
Zeit geredet ich habe alle ne ich habe
die Leute zugetextet die ich vorher
gesehen hab ich muss mein Motor erstmal
an sonst früher wusste ich das nicht bin
einmal die Harald Schmidt schon gegangen
z.B und da wusste ich das noch nicht
schon 10 Jahre her oder
so ja und dann sitze ich in der Maske
und dann war die so nett und war so ich
war war ein bisschen ehfürchtig irgend
dachte was passiert jetzt bin ja nicht
bin ja nicht routiniert in sowas bin ja
kein
talkshowtourist habe ich auch gar keine
Lust dazu guck immer genau wo wo ich was
ich da machen will
und und dann sitze ich da da krieg die Z
nicht auseinander krieg ich die h nicht
auseinander das war eine initialzung da
habe ich das gemerkt
ich bin eigentlich sehr sehr langsam ich
kann schnell sein aber ich bin
eigentlich von von meinem Tempo her
unheimlich langsam
zurückgelehnt so und wenn du mich dann
was fragst dann denke ich lange nach und
denk noch mal nach und spür noch mal
nach und da weiß ich einfach es bringt
euch nichts ihr müsst ja auch irgendwie
das ist auch langweilig für den
Zuschauer wenn wenn er dann irgendwiich
so warten muss bis ich mal auf in die
Gänge komme äh also so viel Profi ist
man ja dann und dann
deswegen und wenn ich drehe in der Figur
dann halte ich die Klappe dann brauche
ich dann meditiere ich irgendwie oder
schlafe oder so in der Maske dann
brauche ich genau das
Gegenteil ja wunderbar dann fühlen wir
uns sehr geehrt dass du als nicht
Talkshow Touristin unsere Einladung
angenommen hast sehr gerne